Tony Stark our beloved iron man started
off the MCU over eleven years ago and
saved the entire universe in Avengers
endgame but did he have a secret a
secret that he himself may not have even
known about what's up everyone it's
Warren and today we're going to talk
about an Iron Man theory a theory that
states that Tony Stark could have
possibly been given the Super Soldier
Serum that's right the same Super
Soldier serum that took tiny little
Steve Rogers and turned him into the
Captain America that we know today your
laboratory experiment Rogers everything
special about you bottle and as it turns
out there is actually quite a bit of
evidence that suggests that he was in
fact given the Super Soldier Serum I'll
break it all down but first quick
reminder if you'd like a chance to win
an Xbox one or a ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment with your favorite superhero
or villain I'm picking a winner at
500,000 subscribers also don't forget to
subscribe to my personal comedy channel
culture captains so on the surface the
theory is pretty simple
Howard Stark the father of Tony Stark at
some point in time injected him with the
Super Soldier Serum like I said on the
surface it's very simple but let's take
a look at all the evidence to back this
we know that dr. arcsine created the
super soldier serum and then Howard
Stark was able to replicate the formula
in fact that very formula is why he and
his wife end up being assassinated by
the Winter Soldier
now obviously before he was assassinated
he saw that the Super Soldier Serum
worked and at some point in time he
could have possibly given some to his
son as an experiment and this actually
makes a lot of sense because if you
think about it in the MCU Tony Stark has
been able to survive a lot of things
that he should really not have survived
just to name a few events that Tony
Stark survived that a normal person
should not have survived starting with
the very first Iron Man Tony survived
shrapnel to the heart not only did he
survive that attack but he fought off
infections as well then in the first
Avengers film he survived going into
space and then in Avengers age of Ultron
he survived a crazy fight with the Hulk
and not to mention in Captain America
Civil War he
literally took on two super soldiers
something that should definitely have
killed him then he survived Thanos
throwing a moon at him in Avengers
infinity war then a major knife wound to
the stomach and an infection following
that up and then of course the Holy
Grail he was able to wield all of the
Infinity stones long enough to snap that
should really not have been possible if
you think about how much the Hulk
struggled right when he put the Infinity
Gauntlet on and think about how little
Tony struggled when he wielded all of
the Infinity stones it doesn't really
make much sense yes Tony did die by the
snap and the Hulk didn't but he really
shouldn't have been able to willed even
one Infinity stone star-lord was barely
able to hold the Power Stone alone for
several seconds without needing the help
of his team and he is part celestial or
he was at that point in time at least
so Tony who was just a human was able to
survive the power of all of the Infinity
stones just simply will Dean at one not
using it but wielding it one of them
should have killed him but he was able
to wield them all and perform the snap
could this be due to the fact that at
some point in time he was given the
Super Soldier Serum it seems like it all
makes perfect sense but I want to know
what you think about this do you think
that Tony Stark at some point in time
was given the Super Soldier Serum be
sure to comment below with what you
think and again don't forget to comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU
don't forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof